hi I'm James I'm studying physics for
GCSE and I want to know what caused the
Big Bang
well James you're studying there for the
GCSE and you want to know what caused
the Big Bang or I would like to know who
so obviously I can't really tell you we
imagine that there was some original
material maybe a small volume of
material that started to expand but
we're guessing what made it do that now
the evidence that we have is that the
universe is expanding and we have ideas
about how the forces of nature work but
so far there's an awful lot of guesswork
here and it's certainly not conclusive
maybe you'll figure this one out
yourself when you come through school